legally blonde three cannot come soon
enough but until then her big screen bae
luke wilson just gave fans a little
something to obsess over
just last week we did a zoom
thing with the cast of legally blonde
who i hadn't seen
you know all together since the movie so
you bend
and snap it was really funny to see
jennifer coolidge and selma blair
and holland taylor and all these people
wow i'm really glad i met you there's
been no comment from reese as to when
the reunion will be shown to fans
she's currently in pre-production on an
upcoming legally blonde
three some returning characters and some
new characters
this is gonna be good did you get an
update on legally blind three did she
say guys it's coming
hold on no i just kind of read that you
know they were writing it
but yeah who knows i mean you never know
luke is of course known for his comedic
roles but starting monday
he will host the new abc reality drama
emergency call
240 million that's how many calls
americans make
every year to 9-1-1 i'm bleeding out
i can't stay awake the series follows
real-life 9-1-1 operators and their
split-second decisions to save
lives there's someone's car getting
stolen with the child in it
they're definitely ones where you know
kind of funny or stuff yes i
have a cat stuck up in a tree
i got to visit a couple of these call
centers i couldn't believe how
interesting it was and they are
like the the first link in the chain of
first responders